welcome to Conan O'Brien needs a friend
I am the aforementioned Conan O'Brien
famed in song and story and I'm joined
as always by Sonam of session hi you
could work on that and uh Matt Gourley
what songs are you famous for being in
just songs about me oh here becomes he's
the great cone and get up and go he's
the funniest guy in the whole wide world
you know songs that are just sung in
general in the popular
American catalog you know it's funny
[Music]
my Jesus
I was just gonna say my kids are
obsessed with there's this soccer player
named Lucas Podolski who he is Eduardo
he played a while ago he's German right
yeah yes and there's this German song
where they sing it for him
[Music]
my boys are obsessed wait how are they
hearing it yeah what station are they
listening to they're not it's not on a
station well how do they know this it's
like a fan made song tack played it for
them and now they're obsessed with it
they just come up and they're like
lululu and so we have to play it for
them all day funny I've been playing my
daughter the original Swedish Pippi
Longstocking thing and she's obsessed
with that are you serious I'm serious
yeah when I was a kid we found
we used to go stay at my grandfather's
house uh down in uh Miss kwamicut Rhode
Island and we went up in the attic once
it had one of those like you know
ladders that you pulled down and it was
this attic that you know stuff had been
up there since the 30s and 40s it was
very musty and we found these old comedy
records and so we would
you know listen to these old records I
remember one of them was yay boo yay boo
it's lots of fun to do if you like it
Holo yay and if you don't you hullabaloo
and
a comedy record yeah exactly and it was
just these kooky records that we would
listen to and this is you know like long
before internet or anything like that so
what else you gonna do on a rainy day
yeah at the State Beach in Miss kwamicut
Rhode Island except listen to yay
I don't know if you're like a holiday
and if you don't fast forward two years
and years later I'm hosting the Late
Night show and this is on the air
and
I'm doing the show and whatever it's
we're a couple years in everything's
Rolling Along we're just cranking out a
show every night and so you just start
to get so loose and at one point I'm
talking to the crowd and I
um made some joke that had like a maybe
word play or something in it and the
crowd playfully was like boo boo and I
went yay boo yay boo it's lots of fun to
do if you like a holiday and if you
don't you Hollow Boo the whole crowd was
like what the was that my producer
Jeff Ross Mike Sweeney everyone's
staring at me
and it just burbled out
and then I remembered this thing that I
heard uh Johnny Carson said uh he didn't
say it to me but he said it uh to
somebody years ago he said when you do a
show every night for an hour everything
in you eventually comes out if you do it
long enough yeah and I it's right this
record that I listened to in the rain on
a rainy day you know in 1971 one that's
completely nonsensical out of nowhere
the crowd boo well yay boo yay you know
and it's just crazy I'm gonna go really
back and talk about your birth with
hellofresh you get Farm Fresh yeah three
portions ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
that's huge I need pre-portioned I know
me too because my portions are out of
control yeah I get too much of something
and then it just goes bad and starts
rotting yeah well you should learn to
use the refrigerator anyway skip trips
to the grocery store and count on
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and get this affordable that's why it's
America's number one meal kit
exclamation point now Sona you've used
hello fresh I have used hello fresh
you've cooked up some nice meals for
attack that's your husband yes I have
and you know what I like about it is
that it does come all in one one box
it's very it's stuff I would never
normally cook on my own and it have
everything you could possibly need in
you know when you're making a recipe and
it's like I'm gonna make clams out
Alfredo yeah and you've got everything
and then you get to the very end I don't
have the clams
doesn't happen with afresh
ofresh.com team coco16 use code team
coco16 for 16 free meals plus free
shipping that's hellofresh.com team
coco16 America's number one meal kit do
you think that's scraping the bottom of
the barrel or that's only like halfway
down oh man there's so much there's also
records we listen to that now are
completely just horrible in retrospect
and Politically Incorrect
um there's one called slapper down again
paw
which was no horrible I mean we didn't
know anything we didn't know what this
what it was all about but it was a
comedy record about uh I think we could
figure you get the idea yeah and it was
47 1947. yeah and you know it was just
there are all these records in the attic
and we would listen to one and you think
um I mean just me even mentioning it
might be triggering to people The
Prodigy came out with an album in 1998
97 and one of the songs was smack my
up and we I went to Coachella one
year and we were singing it and dancing
it and and you but you just weren't
thinking about it we weren't thinking
about the lyric but that's what they say
throughout the whole song and it's a
it's a great song but that lyric is very
problematic right I'll stick with yaboo
I'll stick with her come a Pippi
longstromf wait how does it
goes
what does it mean though Here Comes
Pippi Longstocking with a hope and the
hay and a hope Shauna oh so it does
dissolve into Babel basically okay yeah
I suspected that yeah I knew that that
part and and the song is just in your
songs in German I don't know any of it
but your children know it we listen to
it constantly but like I'm just like I'm
not gonna learn this song I don't know
it I just know Lulu Lucas it sounds like
such a Euro song did you see did you
find it let's hear it it's on YouTube
it's just the Lulu Lucas padoski song
and you're two one and a half year old
yeah well soon to be two-year-old twins
yeah that's right listen to this this is
obsessed with this this is uh how
they're learning about life this is what
this is what you're passing on to yeah
and I don't know what
[Music]
[Applause]
are you guys
oh it's Johnny it's hold on Glory Glory
Hallelujah no it's I think it's
okay
Hallelujah yeah hey uh Eduardo and then
it gets very Euro bring up uh Ingrid
Nielsen's version of hard come a Pippi
longstream you that was the meat of it
you didn't even get to the lululu part
trust me we heard enough wait a minute
and guess what when I hear a lot of
Germans chanting I get nervous
now check this out this is from the
original Pippi Longstocking series sung
by Pippi Ur cell finger Nielsen oh this
there we go this isn't it I'm sorry it's
the one that has a Samba beat starts
with some bongos
Inger Nelson is the key there I think
I'm calling Child Services I know my
kids listen this is so many different
languages that's not it that's not it
either I mean he knows his Pippi
longstock I do I love that you're like
no that's not it that's not it no that's
the studio mix I want the mono track
yeah
no this is the tune but this is a remake
you Eduardo what's going on you
were hired to be able to call up Pippi
Longstocking songs immediately I'll find
it here I got it
[Music]
why is it a Samba
it should be
[Music]
okay now it's my turn okay find yabu
yaboo
who was the artist let me see uh little
Nas because there's a few versions uh
whoa let's let's go back what's what do
you think Arthur Godfrey Arthur Godfrey
yeah he's the one that also I think did
uh the other
um
[Music]
[Applause]
don't you
yep I hear the public school burned down
whatever but they saved the old teacher
Brown
oh my God hold it they're upset
they're upset that the teacher didn't
burn to death where does this go why
does he sound like that uh oh I don't
know it was a different time
he's doing a funny voice for a funny
record
this is back when if you wanted to be
funny you needed to use a funny voice
how come SiriusXM isn't calling us for
DJ sets I have no idea I should have a
channel on SiriusXM that's all music you
can't play anything from the attic yeah
music from my grandfather's attic
people get slapped around what happened
to those records I don't know okay
[Laughter]
say the environment boo I have a cupcake
yeah yeah the wealthy get wealthier yay
ruin the environment yay
um yeah they had different priorities
back then yeah all right well listen I
think we've plumbed the depths of our
childhoods and uh
I can't believe you're letting your kids
hear those songs